you seem to crave
other people's insights into things
whether you incorporate it or not
is is a whole other conversation but you
like to know
hey how did you do that tell me about
this like
how are you thinking you think i'm wrong
are you with me yeah yeah i relish that
that is a for someone who's achieved
your success that is a
a freakishly rare thing what drives that
hmm uh
i don't want to make mistakes anymore i
don't want to mess that up i don't want
to mess this up i want to know how this
works and um you said
the guy that takes the i was the kid
that took the radio or took the
i took my dad out of junk lawnmower and
i took every bolt out of it and took the
engine apart
to learn how the engine worked i had to
know and i don't know
why that was and the next door neighbor
was mean
and he's like uh you want to learn how
spark plug works
oh and um he said here hold this and he
pulled the lawnmower through and knocked
me out
fell backwards that's a hard shock right
there it's worse than
worse than a light socket but um yeah
and i'll never touch spark plug wire
again nope no i was 10. you never listen
to a neighbor either never listen to
that guy again about anything you know
here pull my finger you know right
but the uh uh it seems like the idea
that i have to know how it works and i
i it you know uh
this enneagram stuff everybody studying
uh you know i i am
the quintessential eight uh and eight is
a challenger and i get intimacy
by arguing i enjoy
that and so rachel and i just for sport
yeah
argue we're the worst the two of us we
do it on the air
and we do it at the at the uh easter
table
last sunday you know and so uh i mean
the rest of them are all just watching
you know and it's just like would you sh
you're just you know
you know you're just a conspiracy theory
girl and come on
so i mean it's you know her and her
conspiracy theories but the uh
yeah i get intimacy from that it doesn't
i don't um
it's a it's a rare i'm not mad
i'm just inquisitive yeah but sometimes
people
take that conflict process that i use to
get information
as anger and like we're going to lose
relationship or something over it no i'm
not in this relationship that actually
increases it
gotcha man i wish you could
so one of the the great relational terms
i always want couples to make is going
from
judgment to curiosity when he said that
thing before you bite his head off
stop and don't judge it and say hey tell
me what you meant by that
or vice versa right you responded to
that text from that woman
before i go off the handle tell me about
it
right or okay let's i want to have this
kind of date before you freak out and
call your friend like
that if you could write that book dave
i'm telling you man people
cannot it's it's a rare thing to enter
into
especially when you quote unquote have
made it right
to say tell me about that instead of
just impose will impose will
impose will and that's the thing that i
i've um
i love working with you i had our link
letter on the air
he was here in person before he passed
away
uh inordinately successful in like three
different fields
people knew him from uh he was a
contemporary of walt disney walt disney
was one of his personal friends and he's
telling stories on the air and i was
just enamored
and he was 88 years old when he was here
and he did 78 speaking engagements a
year
i'm like why why
because well when you stop learning and
growing
you are dead whether you do that at 40
or whether you do that at 140.
but he said you might as well stay
engaged because there's all kinds of
aging data
on the brain that says that it is a
muscle and it atrophies when you don't
use it
and he said you know i'm doing 78
speaking engagements and i'm writing
another book this year
and um he's 88 years old and he didn't
need to
financially he didn't need to from a
notoriety standpoint he was an icon at
that point
but it was just to stay engaged and just
to continue to grow because if you're
not growing you're dying
so there's that yeah i just i think
that's
i think that's one of the greatest
things you can one of the greatest gifts
you can bestow upon yourself and those
around you is that
constant tell me how that works let's
take that apart yeah how's it how's that
lawn mower
how does that work how's that lawn mower
work here hold the spark plug
so what makes you a good
dad i don't know it's a different
question you got grown kids versus
little kids
i got 11 year old and a six-year-old
what makes a good dad or made me one you
yeah um well i i was not a great dad
um i was a good dad uh and uh
the the and i got substantially better
in time
just in time before before the formative
years were completely gone and before
teenagers needed to be executed and so
um
we laughingly say our kids turned out
because of the nurturing of their mother
and the fear of their father
um but that you know obviously they were
not
afraid all the time quaking in their
boots from me
um but we had uh
sharon and i both gave them very firm
boundaries
okay um we did not want to create
be disciplinarians to the point that you
create stepford children
uh my friend andy anders says you want
to raise
children who become good adults you
don't want to raise good kids
hmm so you're playing a long game and so
that you know and that affects how
if you let them oh yeah step over there
you
don't do it you know i'm gonna let you
and yeah there you
see there it hurt didn't it you know
grab a spark plug wire right and so you
know you learn those lessons permanently
when you do that
uh but uh you give them enough rope to
find it but not so much rope that they
can be permanently damaged and harmed
and um but they had real firm boundaries
our kids
um but they weren't
like i mean there's always the kids and
i guess there's a spectrum in the
neighborhood we had the
you know you have the hippie parents i
call them and the kids just run wild
right
it's anarchy you know like the two two
little boys on uh
uh what's the wonderful nascar thing
with will
oh ricky bobby
ricky yeah those those two boys those
two kids that's the anarchy kids right
anarchy you know and so uh until grandma
comes in and puts something right
and sets them straight that's kind of
how i grew up you know so
uh but the the parents that don't
believe in giving their children any
boundaries
and so they raise animals not not humans
not adults
and then there's the parents who put so
many boundaries and so and they make all
their decisions for them that the
children develop no critical thinking
skills
and they can't make a decision a moral
decision in the moment they can't make a
a physical harm decision in the moment
because they've never made any decisions
ever
and that's the the the i call them
stafford children well
i'm thinking of the graduate student
parents who would call and ask for
yeah homework assignments and it's like
your kid's 25. like what are you doing
you know you know when we have them call
here when their
28 year old is interviewing and they
want to talk to hr
and we're like well i think we settled
that
pretty much not hiring this one you know
helicopter mother
oh my god woman and so uh yeah there's
that
they do everything for them one of my
friends is a counselor called them
lawnmower parents
they not only helicopter for them but
they mow out
the brush they got a clear path so they
can walk right straight through
and and you know you so you they they
don't have any muscle
structure or uh any bone structure in
their character
to make a decision with but they also
weren't allowed to just run loose
and so there were consequences and moral
things as believers as christians that
it right you're not going to do this
right
and they were physically afraid of
violating those boundaries yeah
so what would you go back and do
different
i would have been more affirming i don't
mind being tough but i would have been
more affirming what does that mean uh i
just would have spent more time uh
more hugs i did plenty of hugs i did i
was like i was there i was emotionally
present those kinds of things but i
would have been warmer
warmer in general and just by that i
mean bragged on them more directly
i did that later as i found it but i
mean it would have been
like one of our granddaughter's um
birthday one of rachel's daughter's
birthday and
we did the happy birthday on easter and
the whole table you know it's 14 i was
sitting there seven kids or six kids and
eight adults and everything and i'm just
looking at little amelia and just
speaking into her
how wonderful she is and how proud
papa dave is of her and how smart she is
and how pretty she is
and you're gonna be a big deal kid
you're amazing and just that little
30-second thing that kid lit up like a
bulba man and her daddy does that all
the time her mama does that all the time
papa dave did it too though this time
and so bragging on myself but i wish i'd
done more of that when mine was that age